vous avez le
bonjour pour sa patrie à donges merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin sénateur de la côte-d'or
président du groupe r des pays l heure
où l on dit encore lrm renaissance
renaissance qui rassemble les sénateurs
de la majorité présidentielle en étant
100 pendant 20 minutes ch pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par christian
bertrand du groupe la dépêche en europe
elle bonjour oriane dont jean françois
patriat un jour on a vu évidemment la
nomination d'elizabeth board françois
patriat ministre depuis cinq ans déjà
est ce qu'on peut porter le quinquennat
nouveau promis par emmanuel macron quand
on a été ministre depuis cinq ans je
crois qu'il faut prendre l'état des
lieux où les défis
auxquels la france doit faire face comme
base de réflexion en la matière vous
avez compris que nous sommes dans le
temps du tragique que nous avons devant
nous des problématiques qui vont se
poser d'inflation de pouvoir d'achat
l'économie lesquels il va falloir à la
fois deux choses 1 de l'expérience et de
la compétence
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
elisabeth bornes rempli ces deux
conditions au delà même que quoi qu'on
en dise
elle vit dans les milieux politiques
depuis 30 ans donc elle est tombée les
politiques aussi
techno pour vous passerez un peu je
pense que le thème je sais qu'on pense
qu'elle est à la fois politique elle a
travaillé avec le premier ministre avec
des ministres elle a dirigé de surcroît
des entreprises privées on a souvent dit
que les politiques étaient déjà hors sol
il connaît pas c'est pas la vie elle
connaît le dialogue social elle a fait
des réformes importantes donc moi je
pense qu'on ces temps où ces temps vont
être difficiles où le plus dur est
devant nous eh bien il faut une femme
d'expérience une femme de compétence qui
est dans le même temps lille altérité
personnel avec les sens politique donc
je crois que ce choix qui était à des
choix le premier si j'ai bien compris du
chef de l'état sur lesquels il a
poursuivi au bout après regardez un peu
comment se passer après
résister moi je pense qu'on le choix
immédiat comme sa brutale s'est jamais
une bonne chose le fait d'avoir regardé
les cas des lieux regardez les forces de
l'opposition possible regardez le bun
peu le débat politique tel qu'il se pose
aujourd'hui pas c'est un choix raisonné
c'est un choix qui était purement
mûrement réfléchie c'est mon choix au
nom de catherine vautrin notamment de la
gauche la majorité dont jeté les clés
qui le responsable de la majorité dont
je ne faisais pas partie samedi ou
dimanche selon ce que j'entends parler
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas moi je n'ai pas
à faire remonter au chef de l'état quoi
que ce soit en la matière mais est-ce
que dole et lons fait richard ferrand
l'a fait peut-être massage vous lui
demanderez je sais pas je ne sais pas
d'information mais jamais je pense
qu'effectivement je pense
qu'effectivement il s'agit pas on a
aussi vu on a beaucoup dit il faudrait
il faudrait qu'elle est une tendance de
gauche ou de droite
cela est dépassé aujourd'hui non pas que
la droite et la gauche n'existe pas mais
qu'il y ait des gens de gauche et des
gens de droit qu'ils puissent travailler
ensemble pour faire avancer ce pays ça
me paraît un souhait que depuis
longtemps les français ont formulé à
vous entendre on a l'impression que vous
dites en ces temps d'insécurité emmanuel
macron a fait le choix de la sécurité
est-ce que ça va être ça le nouvel adn
de ce quinquennat jeu la sécurité en
jean pas le mot sécurité j'en prendrais
le mot souveraineté c'est souveraineté
je parlais des choix d'elisabeth brin
paresseux souveraineté oui si c'est il a
choisi ses 5 milliards de choisir et les
abus de bande pour rétablir toutes les
souverainetés les souveraineté en
matière de défense la souveraineté
alimentaire la souveraineté et dans
l'énergie la souveraineté écologique la
souveraine dans tout l'est la france moi
je pense que le le thème le mot clé de
ce quinquennat c'est souveraineté
aujourd'hui mais dans le casting
habituellement le chef de l'état nous
avait appris à choisir des noms peu
attendu là c'est quelqu'un vous l'avais
déjà dit qui a été citée dès le départ
est ce que ce nouveau quinquennat va
être celui de moins de surprises et plus
de d'abord attendant le gouvernement moi
j'ai ressenti vernement 7 connaît pas la
composition du gouvernement je ne serai
bien entendu pas pas interroger mais ce
que je veux moi ce que je vois les
choses il faut de l'expérience de la
sécurité avec des gens déjà connaît ses
dossiers qui déjà nous repas des des
semaines pour se mettre pour se mettre à
côté donc je pense qu'il y aura des
ministres sortants qui me fait trop de
rio qui ont fait un très bon et mec qui
aura ça peut être un tiers 2/3 je ne
sais pas mais à côté vraiment du
renouvellement pour apporter une énergie
nouvelle un souffle nouveau je pense que
les deux il faut à la fois il faut à la
fois du solide politiquement il faut du
renouveau politiquement aussi petit
aussi du technique donc quand le chef de
l'état dit ce sera un nouveau
quinquennat s'est pas inquiété qu'à être
plus mais un nouveau quinquennat ce sera
avec les mêmes personnes que les cinq
années qui viennent ne s'est posée y
aura je pense qu'il y aura une partie
des mêmes personnes ne pense pas qu'il y
aura que les mêmes personnes il en faut
plus pour
un deuxième quinquennat moi je le fais
le voeu que je formule connaissant et
soutenant avec ardeur à manuel macron
c'est que j'ai vu les deuxième
quinquennat du président précédent
j'ai pas apprécié françois mitterrand
georis le soutenait et ses problèmes
c'est toujours difficile un deuxième
quinquennat parce qu'on sait que le
temps est limité mais inversement c'est
une opportunité extraordinaire et quand
je connais la volonté de réforme des
manuels macron je me dis voilà qui est
un président qui est libéré de sa
réélection en 2027 après on verra mais
la première après on verra en 2032
annoncé me dire qu'il peut ravir à 2030
de la série pourrait finalement il
politiquement
montre en main
jeudi au moins en 2027 oui je le dis
pour sourire un peu ce matin mais tout
est possible quand on connaît le cursus
plaint déjà fait ensemble donc je 2007
il est libéré donc il peut il est en
mesure de pouvoir faire des réformes
moi je le pense parce qu'il y aura des
réformes à hauteur d'homme des réformes
du quotidien on voit bien ce qu'est le
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui revient que
son et transport vous laisse que sont
tous le pôle se loger ce qu'on va bien
l'urgence haute sanitaire aujourd'hui
autour de la santé oms voix pour l'école
aussi donc si serré formule 1 il va les
faire il ya peut-être des réformes on va
t'en doutes parler des retraites mais
des réformes comme je pense la réforme
des institutions cela dit il faudra à
mon avis fier des réformes
additionnelles alors je sais que déjà
l'opposition qui joue un match retour
qu'elle s'est perdue d'avancé dans
lequel je fais beaucoup de communication
aujourd'hui pense déjà à un troisième
tour je sais très bien que c'est pour
cela qu'il faut de l'expérience
politique qu'il faut du calme du
sang-froid mais de la compétence parce
que il y aura des réticences à certaines
réformes un des défauts qui a été
pointée du doigt du premier quinquennat
c'est la relation avec les élus locaux
et la relation avec les territoires on a
dit c'est au gouvernement et ce
président la république n'était pas
suffisamment ancrées dans les
territoires elisabeth borne n'a pas été
élu est-ce que c'est pas ça va pas être
un handicap pour elle de ne pas avoir
été élu et de n'entretenir pas de liens
privilégiés avec les élus locaux lors de
choses des choses et les aveux de borne
n'a pas été élu mais et compris qu'elle
a travaillé déjà dans les territoires et
en particulier elle a été présidente là
était préfète de région
si vous pensez qu'elle préfète de région
prenant le travail et pas avec les élus
moi je travaille avec mon préfet tous
les jours mais tous les jours et le
couple élus préfets
c'est quelque chose et un préfet salle
apprend à connaître mais mes petits
dossiers de territoire de le faire je
sais que je le peux je le pense comme
tel et c'est pas pareil
le
népal et le calmer vous avez pris j'ai
échappé que emmanuel macron n'était pas
élu local quand il est élu comme un vrai
public
il n'a pas été élu local et ça l'a pas
étonnant en empêcher d'être un grand
brun dans la république qui de surcroît
est réélu après cinq ans hors
cohabitation
deuxième chose deuxième chose à d
sur le plan des îles locaux vous dites
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron clore là je
m'inscris totalement en faux témoins
bien un faux parce que jamais un présent
la république n'a autant rencontrer les
élus qui est venu battre ont géré la
crise des gis les gens mais avant cela
les temps mais tout le temps en maître
bien avant j'avais fait avec cuda grand
d'itinérance tout à l'heure tu es on a
parlé de moselle qui fait la grande
l'itinérance en 2018 c'était avant les
gilet jaune juste avant on a passé dix
jours huit jours entre l'alsace et le
nord pas de calais a rencontré tous les
soirs tous les soirs il y avait des
réunions la journée il y avait des
réunir les élus le matin il y avait le
soir des rencontres avec les élus et là
on a rencontré cette année le chef de
l'état à l'époque des dizaines ou même
des centaines de maires à ce moment là
jamais regardé qu'est ce qui a le plus
reçu les maires à l'elysée c'est qui
avant les gilets jaunes c'est emmanuel
macron tous les ans reçoit 1000 maires à
l'elysée pour les rencontrer et il se
bat pourrait venir et me demande tous le
pouvoir entrer tous les jours tout le
monde tous les maires mois tous les
maires de ma circonscription fait un
selphy avec emmanuel macron je n'ai
jamais vu avant mais qu'aucun progrès la
république donc et les corps
intermédiaires la même chose tu es
gouvernement j'ai bien vu ce qu'a fait
dur filippi castex les corps
intermédiaires étaient toutes les
semaines à matignon moi je serais déçu
ce discours qui dit il s'est coupé avec
les corps intermédiaires et les maires
jamais le couple maire préfet n'a aussi
bien marché qu'aujourd'hui on va revenir
sur les réformes puisque évidemment
on va parler d'un enfant vous me disiez
tout à l'heure qu'il faut faire des
réformes dures est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut aller au bout de la réforme
des retraites qu'il faut repousser l'âge
légal et à combien pour vous est-ce
qu'il doit aller jusqu'à 65 ans je pense
que j'ai entendu dire un opposant un
député la reine qui immédiatement le
premier qui ne soit pas terminé
continuer à charger avec une violence
des sarcasmes l'extrême le chef de la
chef de l'état dira c'était pas l'âge
qui compte c'est le nombre d'annuités
sipa le dispatcheur d'un invité mais en
fait ça revient à la même chose parce
que si vous mettez temps d'annuités vous
arrivez à 64 65 ans ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron il a dit mon objectif c'est que
ce soit 65 ans avec avec trois choses 1
il y aura trois âges de la retraite 55
pour les handicaps 62 plus carrières
longues et 65 pour les autres il a dit
trois choses 2 il faut aujourd'hui je
veux maintenant que la retraite tous
m'ont dit que la retraite est trop
faible je vais la mettre à 1100 euros
tout de suite pour les habitats sur wii
il faut c'est pas seulement paramétrique
financiers je crois que et regardez les
pays autour de nous je veux bien moi
parce que quand personne ne le dit mais
écoutez quand on dit retraite à 60 ans
aujourd'hui quand le dit madame le pen
comme le dit monsieur mélenchon ça veut
dire la faillite du système immédiate
parce que la retraite plein à 60 ans
alors ça c'est pas le corps qui va vous
dire qu'on peut la payer aujourd'hui et
quand le corps dit le régime est à
l'équilibré social et qu'il y manquait
l'année en 2070 entre-temps nommé donc
vous dites il faut aller jusqu'à 65 ans
je pense que lorsque je pense qu'il faut
maintenant mais commencer attendez on
veut manière progrès l'ancien coin et
non 5 à 10 et ça mais je perds 25 ans et
vous a pas échappé qu'à la fin du mandat
momentanée l'espère d'emmanuel macron et
bien ce sera 60 et si vous revenez à
2003 2 532 sera même au delà du coût
mais ce sera soit 24,2 sera 64 en 2027
donc là il est dit à ce moment-là et
franchement ce qu'ils n'ont pas chez moi
je fais et j'espère que nous allons
faire pression qui reculaient un peu non
sur les 65 ou en disant on va attendre
la fin de mon mandat effectivement ça
sera quasiment 60 après on nous dit non
il faut aller jusqu'à 65 je vous vous
auriez pu me poser la question me mettra
en difficulté moi j'ai voté la retraite
à soixante à soixante ans c'était il ya
les cds à 41 excusez-moi bon j'ai voté
je me souviens la cinquième semaine à
l'époque les 35 heures j'étais beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus beaucoup plus modérée
mais là à l'époque à l'époque je veux
dire que les gens avaient des métiers
manuels qui était beaucoup plus dure
qu'aujourd'hui y compris dans le
bâtiment quand on travaillait sur les
charpentes ont monté tout à la main
maintenant vous avez des appareils de
manitou c'est pas la même chose les
métiers sont encore pénible très pénible
ils le sont encore élevés ils le sont
encore ya quarante ans le monde y
compris le monde du travail et lesquels
ils travaillent n'est pas celle
d'aujourd'hui
donc vous pousser à aller jusqu'à 65 ans
je pense que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
regarder ce que font les pays européens
autour de nous 67 65 partout je pense
que le l'objectif d'arriver à 65 ans
avec avec grade et chatila pénibilité
prise en compte les carrières longues et
étrangers le pont et la carrière à 1100
groupe mais ça veut dire que dans les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
l'âge ne sera pas un élément de
négociation je crois que non mais c'est
à dire que l'âge les conditions des
négociations de l'âge sont sur la table
différents c'est pas la can événements
des sessions sert dire voilà 65 ce sera
pour les personnes
qui travaillent à voir travail de burin
c'est-à-dire à dire qu'elle allait finir
par contre pour les gens et qui tous les
jours manier un marteau piqueur
repris aux doudous des dames je pense
par exemple à des dom parce qu'on parle
souvent du travail des hommes paisibles
mais pour les femmes sera en travaux
pénibles ça existe beaucoup aussi par
exemple est dingue je sais qui plume des
volailles dans des milieux super
hydrique etc c'est très fatigant que
fumeuse des hommes qui travaillent donc
oui non mais tenir compte de la
pénibilité
le taux plein à 67 ans aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il faut le décaler ou est-ce qu'il
faut les laisser à 67 là je pense qu'il
faut espérer en faire que tout le monde
puisse avoir à 65 ans demain c'est que
soit qu'ils soient remis à 65 des mains
tendues un dernier mot là dessus puisque
elisabeth borne a été très vite attaqué
par jean luc mélenchon dès les premières
minutes de sa nomination vous avez sans
doute vu ça où il dit c'est une des
figures les plus durs de la maltraitance
social macro nisme que vous répondez à
ça je réponds que les excès les
outrances des luc mélenchon font des
beaux effets de tribune font de belles
promesses aujourd'hui qui ne sont
absolument pas tenable je crois que
quelqu'un chiffré hier
christophe castaner qui a chiffré le
niveau là si on applique le programme de
monsieur mélenchon ses 270 milliards
d'euros de dette dans cinq ans ça veut
dire que si vous êtes à ménages français
qui aujourd'hui gagne 2000 euros par
mois et qu'il dépenserait 3800 euros par
mois ça n'irait pas longtemps mais est
ce qu'elle est dure en négociation
elisabeth bord non parce que si
quelqu'un n'est pas dur je crois que les
bains il faut demander aux gens qui ont
travaillé à la ratp
je pense elle a travaillé dans des
groupes privés à trouver cheffaj aussi
je pense que mes en négociation il faut
à la fois être ferme sur les objectifs
mais être souple sur les principes sur
les modalités pour arriver à ce que
l'objectif qui pas l'intérêt des
habitants d'être madame morano et chef
de l'état qui est l'intérêt de la france
il a aujourd'hui et je crois que la
réforme de la sncf telle qu'elle a été
faite j'entends bien on l'a vilipendé
mais qu'est ce qu'en pensent les
français id mois et france et israël ont
accepté il dit les français globalement
l'ont accepté et elle est passée comme
tel et même la réforme la réforme de
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui quand on
voit gt gt chez ses anciens amis le
dimanche qu' un petit restaurant qui m'a
dit je ne gardais je ne peux je peux pas
servir je pourrais avoir deux salles
pleines je n'en fais qu'une puisque je
ne trouve personne ce que je trouve pas
de serveuse aujourd'hui je me sens pas
de serveur vous rendez compte on les
bloque aujourd'hui parce qu'on doit on
doit remettre quand même et ce
gouvernement a quand même pour le de
voyous non il était de gauche on sait
qu'il a réduit la plus grande des
inégalités qu'elles chômage le chômage
des jeunes et la formation des jeunes
hier élisabeth berne a rendu visite aux
députés de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale vous y étiez aussi quelque
part elle a lancé un peu la bataille des
législatives ces législatives risque de
se conclure par un groupe de gauche
assez important à l'assemblée nationale
voir le premier groupe d'opposition est
ce que ça va changer quelque chose à la
tonalité du quinquennat d'avoir à
répondre à la nuque le groupe de gauche
plutôt qu à l'air et à christian jacob
lors il ya deux choses le premier lieu
il est certain que la déperdition que
vont avoir à la fois les socialistes et
le républicain la mesure peut être plus
réactif qu'on ne le dit plus relative
connolly je pense que quand on dit 30 au
but quand je pense pas je pense qu'il y
en aura plus bon les sociétés
qui peuvent être très bien soit ils
peuvent être 60 demain peu de 60 demain
bon je pense d'abord que le gouvernement
aura la majorité
il aura la boj dans libé long chemin
vers dieu pour moi m'a cramé l'utopie
d'abord le scénario jean luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon installer des facto
avec une réactivité qu'on lui connaît et
neutre en ce qu'on lui connaît le match
de l'an miles il a installé le match ce
qui dans l'esprit des français
tactiquement et bien sa part maintenant
est-ce que c'est crédible alors donc je
pense que cbs et déperdition qui vont se
faire sur les partis classiques vont se
reporter sur les partis extrêmes le
groupe front national peut monter à 30
40 par
le groupe nuxe peut monter aussi à
plusieurs dizaines dont trois pôles bon
ce qui va changer c'est que moi je
regarde sur mon territoire le territoire
que je connais pas mon territoire
territoire où j'habite pardon où il ya
27 députés il ya dix sept sortants la
même je pense que je vois qu'il y aura
une stabilité voire peut-être un gain
pour notre part que je ne vois pas mais
je ne vois pas comment traduire
l'électorat mélenchon nationale sur un
est ce que tu as dit mon prédécesseur
avant sur une mission de
circonscriptions locales ça ne fait pas
comme ça elle des candidats qu'ils
soient connus d'autres qui ont déjà
connu avant alors ce qui va changer vous
avez raison c'est que comme c'est des
partis qui sont aujourd'hui qu'ils
songent à dire qu'ils disent qu'ils
s'assoient sur les règles de la
république qui sont capables d'être
provocateur tous les jours il est
certain que le ton va changer le ton
changera et wadi la chienlit mais j'ai
dit on voit bien comment aujourd'hui des
insoumis avec vingt députés ont réussi à
faire comme bruit par rapport aux jo
république à l'époque et aux voter quand
même grande partie des textes pendant ce
quinquennat
ça va être le ton provocateur tous les
jours les excès les débats n'en plus
finir souvent pour faire durer les
débats les multiplications d'amendements
je le vois il va falloir s'y préparent
et bien d'autres qu'on soit patriat ce
groupe majoritaire va avoir des
postes-clés à l'assemblée nationale la
vice-présidence la présidence de la
commission des finances un poste de
questeur est ce que ça vous inquiète eu
égard à ce que vous venez de dire ça ça
m'inquiète pas malgré tout parce que je
crois qu'au delà ce qui peut dire sur
l'europe sur les traités sur le reste et
sans républicain ce républicains
voulaient voir l'a pas vu y siègent à
l'europe ici un jeu dont un député en
surrégime à la présidence de la
commission des finances ont changé
beaucoup de choses
c'est vrai c'est pour la commission des
finances n'est pas lui qui décide c'est
la commission et la commission il sera
majoritairement partie de la majorité
donc il pourra toujours à bord des
prises de parole et pour avoir des
prises de positions mais ça changera pas
je crois le déroulement est ce que est
ce que françois patriat le ton sera
sûrement bien entendu mais ce que je
souhaitais qu'il changera en bien je ne
suis pas convaincu est-ce que vous qui
venez du parti socialiste vous discuté
aujourd'hui avec les membres ou les
ex-membres je pense à bernard cazeneuve
du parti socialiste qui n'ont pas
rejoint la nuque bernard cazeneuve non
puisque je n'ai pas rencontré et mais
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié et d'estimé pour
bernard cazeneuve mais j'ai rencontré
des sénateurs socialistes que je
connaissais avant j'ai rencontré hier en
allant la décoration de mon ami laurent
grandguillaume beaucoup de responsables
socialistes qui étaient j'ai rencontré
jean marie le guen enfin je vous donne
10 rencontrés autour de moi mais
bien sûr que je pourrais travailler avec
bien sûr elles ont le canard par exemple
patrick kanner par exemple patrick
keller me semble dans une position très
inconfortable très inconfortable parce
que sa vision vis-à-vis des nuls ça a
été tellement
variable auquel main et puis en plus ce
savez moi je sais que patrick n'hésite
pas à critiquer ses ex amis ou ses
adversaires je le ferai pas je pense que
patrick kanner je place la situation est
inconfortable parce que son groupe
aujourd'hui moi je fais pas je vais pas
aller chercher du démarchage c'est pas
ça ceux qui veulent venir avec nous
viennent avec lui mais y'en a qui vont
dire simplement socialistes ont l'avenir
avec vous y en a qui m'ont dit je
m'interroge sur la survie du groupe tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui entre les ultras
tour de manège rossignol auteurs
d'autres qui sont vraiment très dur
aujourd'hui et ceux qui ne comprennent
pas l'attitude aboya cieux dans le
groupe qui n'acceptent pas d'accord avec
le nikkei en a beaucoup rachid t'es
malade cela donne comme tel bon y en a
plusieurs qui prévalent unis d'où est ce
là aussi le dis comme tel bon y'en a qui
n'accepte pas donc je crois qu'ils ont
le choix entre trois positions a cédé
devant la majorité du groupe si elle est
la majorité
rejoindre l'état majorité ou faire un
groupe autonome car je pense qu'il
serait plus tôt je pense qu'il serait
plutôt sont plutôt enclins à faire un
groupe autonome carole delga et donc la
séparation ne sais pas
j'ai dit qu'il y avait trois
possibilités carole delga pardon est en
train de fédérer autour d'elle un groupe
de candidats qui partent en dissidence
de face au candidat de la nuque est ce
que vous pourriez discuter avec ce
groupe là par exemple est ce que ça
pourrait être un appui aurait manuelle
malot je pense que ces députés là ce
sont pas franchement favorable à la
majorité mais qu'ils existent à côté
parce que d'avoir cédé à ce point rendez
compte parce que là
là il ya les insoumis et elle est
soumise
ils se sont carrément soumis 70
candidats bourgogne franche comté une
candidate socialiste sur 27 sièges une
sorte entre en compte est bon elle est
un peu dans une terre comme comme le
notait comme le tarn et garonne comme
tout le pays tout occitanie avec le
nombre d'élus socialistes ou là c'est la
majorité socialiste est importante
imaginez qui n'est plus que six ou sept
députés possible possible humble donc
ces dissidences alors je pense que les
dissidences vont se multiplier encore
dans les jours qui viennent françois
mettrait en a parlé des socialistes et
au sénat est aussi le groupe centriste
qui actuellement est allée au
républicain il fait partie de la
majorité sénatoriale donc de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron hervé
marseille était à votre place la semaine
dernière il le disait qu'il était plutôt
ouvert pour travailler avec le
gouvernement est ce que vous discutez
avec lui et est ce que là aussi des
sénateurs centristes qui pourrait vous
rejoindre et sk revue mars à y croire et
travailler avec vous lors ya deux choses
1 discuter avec bien entendu mois si
tout à fait ouverts et puis j'ai
rencontré des parlementaires centristes
mais je ne leur ai pas dit qu'ils
thévenet car le discours est ce que vous
pouvez penser contre tous ceux entre
monsieur malhuret le groupe ''le entre
des socialistes qui aujourd'hui pourrait
travailler avec nous et éventuellement
sénat vous comprenez on quitte pas son
groupe comme ça parce qu'au départ de
saleh centriste pour mon vieux ce sera
toujours à la marge que ça se passera
c'est parce que j'aime mais je pense que
les présentes groupes vont tout faire
pour les retenir à cauterets heures vous
êtes libre vous êtes bien il n'empêche
qu'un à deux ans qui sont mal à l'aise y
en a qui sont mal à l'aise au groupe
républicain ils me le disent il me
téléphone je les rencontre qui sent mal
à l'aise qu'ils se sentent pas bien dans
la ligne qui n'ont pas bien senti là qui
n'ont pas accepté la ligne ni ni et quel
calcul et quelques dizaines peut-être le
cas zinc et qui le font ces gens là les
voir quitter le groupe comprenait il
dans un an il ya les élections
sénatoriales
et les sénateurs il pense alors
élections l'année prochaine et ce disque
de changer ou d'apartés d'un groupe ça
peut créer des dissidences ieseau des
difficultés dont qu'ils hésiteront
beaucoup je l'entends je le comprends ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est que ces
gens au delà de quitter leur groupe
c'est parce qu'ils feront tout est dit
qu'elles étaient les opportunités y
compris au groupe centriste il ya au
moins vingt ou vingt-cinq centriste qui
vont voter avec nous maintenant
de là le poste je sais je pense pas
qu'ils le font comme tel
j'ai parlé avec environ marseille
souvent je m'entoure bien hervé
marseille est quelqu'un de très
conviviale de dessouder taule je fais
mais ça veut pas dire par là moi je suis
pas dans les opérations de débauchage je
suis dans l'attractivité qui veulent
venir qu'ils violent et nanard question
france abattra d'actualité cette
décision la décision à grenoble sur
l'autorisation du burkina dans les
piscines l'association des maires de
france appelle à une clarification
législatives est ce que vous êtes prêt à
porter est ce qu'il faut modifier la loi
là dessus des
répits la dit lui-même c'est un non
événement et dans le même temps ça dit
un événement national
moi je le conseil d'état ou savez avait
autorisé sur le pacs verra là on est
dans le domaine public que je pense que
eric piolle cède cède à des groupes de
pression aujourd'hui qu'il est l'otage
des groupes de pression d'un certain
temps savent ils que c'est une erreur de
d'ouvrir ce débat de le permettre me
savais suppan adeptes dans la carignon
mais j'ai trouvé que le communiqué qu'il
a fait correspond exactement à ce que je
perçois syndicale voilà mes donc les
oies au parc clarification législatives
ou pas je te le dis le débat va se poser
puisque monsieur ciotti va le déposer va
le déposer le texte de leur on verra
comment il évoluera codé quelle est
votre position vous laisse moi je suis
pas favorable au bord de bookeen à la
fission voilà je pense aujourd'hui parce
que demander demandé haut et ça va être
demandée demander aux gens de ce côté
comme l auteur s il accepte le topless à
côté je suis pas sûr qu'il soit inscrit
dans la loi
non c'est du règlement c'est pas moi
c'est dur et ne faut pas qu'il faut pas
être la négation la liste aix merci
françois patriat merci beaucoup il était
notre invité on regarde la une de la
dépêche du midi impôt sur le revenu
déclaré mal an les bons plans à la une
lui durci cristal merci merci françois
patriat
[Musique]